en este vídeo quiero explorar las
consecuencias de una fórmula muy bonita
que discutimos en uno de los vídeos de
cálculo y esta es la fórmula de hoy les
fórmula fórmula de oilers
para quienes no lo recuerden la fórmula
de avilés lo que hacía era relacionarme
la exponencial con el coseno y el seno
en términos de ciertos números
imaginarios así que bien en sí la
fórmula de hoy leer dice que era la y
theta y bueno la fórmula es bastante
interesante pero se torna aún más
interesante cuando sustituye el valor de
teta igual a pi o a tau si no saben lo
que está hay unos vídeos muy
interesantes al respecto en el sitio ok
entonces era la ite está la fórmula de
hoy leer nos dice que esto es igual a
coseno de peta coseno dt está más veces
el seno de eta y bueno si nos fijamos en
esta expresión quizás sea interesante
preguntarnos si podemos expresar a
coseno de teta y hacen o beteta en
términos de esta exponencial así que
bueno vamos a considerar antes que nada
qué pasa si en vez de considerar a la y
theta consideró
a la menos y theta quién sería esto pues
puede escribir esto como ala y por menos
theta como paréntesis aquí y esto sería
igual a quien pues la fórmula de hoy
leer me diría que esto es si aquí
sustituyó de está igual a menos theta
entonces esto me daría goce no de menos
teta
más veces
el seno de menos teta ahora bien
nosotros sabemos que el coche no es una
función par así que cosenos de menos
teta es igual a coseno de teta esto
sería lo mismo que coseno de 30
y el seno por el contrario es una
función impar
así que estreno en menos theta es igual
a menos 0 etc así que estoy acá sería lo
mismo que menos y veces el seno de teta
perfecto entonces decirme lo que escribo
por acá abajo y ala - itt
va a ser igual a josé noé teta coseno
eta
- y veces el seno de teta ahora bien qué
sucede qué sucede si se me ocurre sumar
estas dos expresiones qué pasa si la
sumo pues por un lado tendría qué
era la jeepeta
más
era la menos cita
sería igual a cuánto
pues veamos coseno de teta más coseno de
teta es dos veces coseno de teta
y veces el seno de teta menos y veces el
seno de teta pues estas dos cosas se
cancelan y simplemente me queda esto de
modo que si yo aquí divido entre dos y
entre dos de ambos lados estos doce se
cancelan y obtengo que el coste no de
teta es igual a ea la ite está más a la
y
obtengo que coser no de teta es igual a
la que está más a la menos y está entre
2 déjenme lo noto acá abajo
lo que obtuvimos fue que coseno de teta
beteta es igual
a la teta
más más
a la menos y peta
entre 2
perfecto ahora qué pasa con el seno bien
pues como el coseno y el seno
generalmente son funciones que están muy
relacionadas porque no probamos en vez
de sumar estas cosas qué pasa si le
restamos así que bien déjenme lo escribo
acá y ala y theta
yo sé que es consejero beteta con seno
de eta
más veces el seno de teta seno dt está
perfecto ahora lo que voy a hacer es
restar la ok entonces voy a considerar
menos
a la menor y teta
y eso cuánto es pues sería multiplicar
todo esto por menos así que sería menos
coseno de teta menos conocen a beteta
- menos beteta es decir más veces
el seno de theta perfecto entonces voy a
sumar estas dos cosas que equivale a
restarle esto a esto
esto me da
era la teta
menos
a la menos si te está y esto cuánto es
igual
jose no detectan menos coseno beteta se
cancelan me da 0 y por el otro lado esta
parte y se no hay temas y seno beteta me
daría dos veces y seno de teta así que
si quiero despejar el seno de teta
simplemente dividido todo esto entre dos
y
y también de este lado
entre 12 estados y cancela este 12 y
obtengo que ese no etc es igual a a la z
- el ala menos y te está entre 2 y
déjenme también lo noto por acá también
ahora sé que seno de teta
es igual a la zeta
- era la menos y teta
sobre todo si y si no les gusta tener
está ahí en el denominador pueden
multiplicar por ella entre y cancelar
está ahí
pero bueno esto es un resultado bastante
interesante porque me permite expresar
al coseno y al seno en términos de estas
funciones exponenciales complejas el
cose no resulta ser el promedio entre el
ala y teta y el ala menos y teta y el
seno resulta ser el ala y teta menos a
la menos y theta entre 2 y bien pues ya
que tengo estas dos funciones expresadas
en términos de estas exponenciales
quizás me gustaría preguntarme si hay
alguna relación entre funciones de este
tipo y las funciones trigonométricas
podría inspirarme en estas funciones y
tratar de definir nuevas funciones así
que vamos a hacer eso vamos a definir
una definición lo que voy a llamar cos
coseno hiperbólico tx simplemente como
la función de este estilo pero quitando
la siss que va a hacer eso pues sería
a la x más a la menos x entre
entre 2
y también voy a definir lo que sería
inspirándome ahora en el seno
sen
qué suena raro pero viene xenón
hiperbólico y sería simplemente a la x
menos ea la - x todo eso entre 2
y eventualmente en algún vídeo en el
futuro veremos que estas dos funciones
en realidad si tienen una relación pues
no mágica pero bella una relación bella
y muy interesante con las funciones
trigonométricas y entre ellas y déjenme
decirles algo estas dos funciones quizás
no forman parte de el núcleo de las
funciones que verán en su curso de
cálculo pero aún así vale la pena
estudiarlas pues son funciones muy
interesantes y muy bellas